blow and I again we know not no selling
out like venues blow and I bl's blown up
so much in the past like 3 years and
it's so [__] cool and I don't know
there's something I wanted to give you
your flowers on I don't know if people
know how hard you hustled when you
didn't have money like there's a story I
think we told it on patreon years ago I
don't know if you remember Blau couldn't
get booked I was in a similar position I
couldn't get booked but what Blau did
was he would email comedy clubs pretend
to be an agent what was his name Chris
Chris McCormack Chris M that man yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he would send it to
comic the country and then some of them
would book he'd send on behalf of
Michael blow with the real and
everything and sometimes he'd get booked
and then that's just what it is like
this guy has [__] hustled man SE Bo
used do with lme wire he used to change
it to like like like Taylor Swift then
it would just be cranked at yeah you
download it what the [__] is this what
is this yeah oh man and so it's very
cool just again as a brother to watch
you and the what feels like the past six
months it just went crazy six months so
it's was very cool to watch and I just
want to give you love publicly on that
thank you man yeah it's uh he kind of
sent me a blast patreon just sort of
talk about like where I was like when I
first got to like New York and then
where we're at now it's a really it's a
it's a wild it's a wild transition well
I knew that BL we thought was going to
take the [__] off in like 2010 or
something because he was on punked Yeah
we actually have one of your your videos
that we could pull up puning yeah it's
you punking um Chloe Kardashian with
Miley withy andw s on it we could pull
this up and play fat Chloe or skinny
Chloe which one uh bigger Chloe it's big
but she's actually if you watch it we'll
watch and but she's actually like so
[__] likable through this thing she's
really being sweet just watch that's
young dud look how young he is so you go
to Miley's house ask if you can use a
bathroom as a delivery boy as a Del and
then he's just screaming now so can we
pause real quick shut up so this is
there any backstory that we need to know
any like cool info about this how do
they tell you what you're going to do
when do you find out what's that whole
process like dude the this this show is
actually crazy man because you find out
so last minute cuz you're not I'm not
writing on it yeah so I'm just kicking
it and you get like an email or a phone
call and they go meet me at the studio
and you have to like just sort of be on
call and you meet there and then they
just tell you what it is and and when
you got there Miley's the host she's
pranking people punking people is she in
there with you in the studio like is she
involved in all of it um I mean like
vaguely it's it's a lot of like the what
it's a lot of the writers doing it you
know um but it's a it's a very like go
go go type thing cuz every like these
people are hyper famous obviously so
their schedules are so insane so when
they lock things you have to go so it's
a very like there's no like time to
think sort of and they like told me what
the bit was sort of like on the way to
the house like it's a it was it's and
then the thing that really [__] me up
the most in this show is the go go go
but also the earpiece so there's an
earpiece there's a director talking to
you there's a prod talking to you and
some of the actors like Santino helped
write a lot of these he's so funny and
Sh s s so funny and a lot of this he's
like he's also in video Village talking
to me so there's like three people
walking me through stuff and they might
throw me some lines and I have to decide
if I want to say the line that's in my
head or the line that they're saying and
it's a there's a lot of things that are
and then you also also just trying to
play it cool you don't have an earpiece
in there correct and you yeah exactly
you also have to like and it's the
earpiece it's got to be super subtle
right it's super subtle can we can we
play out and see how the rest is Al you
haven't seen this right no this is
great so the prank is he has his nut
caught in the zipper right it's like
sticking out ball is caught in the
[__] zipper it's art it's art it's an
art ball so it looks real so here's the
restro went to the restroom and
accidentally she's like really talking
to she's like being very sweet
andth any kind of seal fluid coming out
of the genitals is there
any was so cute she's like is there any
fluid coming out like she's like being
really what color is the general right
now I mean it looks a little red are we
talking like salmon pink does it look
salmon pink in color Miss I've never
seen a white penis before I don't know
I've never seen a white penis before so
sincere yeah she was super nice to dude
that made she's so likable In that clip
cuz she's like genuinely concerned about
your testic whereas I think a lot of
girls would be like I don't buddy deal
with that ran away yeah I think my wife
would be like you got that you [__]
weirdo Uber figure out 100% she's always
with the coolest Kardashian yeah it's
actually so sweet did you talk to her
after what like do you have any
interaction did she say anything to you
good job let me see the real nut I think
they they all kind of like shuffled off
pretty fast like one start like hey it's
Punk they don't really care about me
they're just it's her it's her and Miley
and uh the what's Kelly Osborne so
they're all like homies and they're not
going to be like hey do you want to come
out BL but they didn't really talk to me
did you get to work with Miley a lot
she's again the head of the episode in
uh three the yeah cuz everyone everyone
hosts one episode and then they have
three EP or three punks within one
episode so I think that was the only one
I worked with Miley but Miley's cool as
[__] really so nice dude oh it's great
to hear so nice and her husband at time
hot oh the H's worth boy the hottest
family in the world I think it might be
she was with a she was with a hems worth
I don't remember which one not not the
the Chris not Chris no no both of them
are pretty you know yeah they done who
is Chris with cuz what a lucky lady
somebody deserving I hope like his
hammer you're getting there
quick so funny about this if you were
just how how hot it was and then you
going to [__] on me you 3 seconds ago
the hottest film life he's a piece but
you're
gay oh man that's what we do that is
what we do but I remember BL going out
to that and then so I did whing out and
I was telling him how cuz whing out is
similar stress you find out the night
before who the guest is you don't know
what the [__] game is going to be
there's like a boot camp for two weeks
where they just drill you to death and
then I was telling that to blow he was
like thank God somebody finally
understands what Punk was like he
because I was we're broke as [__] so
we're thinking blows on Punk this is
crazy it's about to take the [__] off
and then he was just like yeah it was
cool but it wasn't the most fun dog it
was not it there was moments of fun for
sure but it was just so it was so
stressful and it's a very it's like
operated I mean I've never done SNL so I
don't really know but operates very much
like that where it's like you're not
guaranteed episodes yeah so like they'll
just call you or they won't and then so
you just I'm just in La for there might
be I mean there was a time where like
two weeks straight I didn't hear from
them so I'm just in La broke his [__]
supposedly on a show yeah but I I
haven't done an episode in two weeks so
it's a mind [__] and the funniest thing
I think I told you this TR the funniest
thing was we had I had like screen test
so I had to come into LA and then there
doing a bunch of like improv games with
me blah blah blah and I was in the
Creator's office and then Ashton comes
in yeah and he opens the door and he
goes uh goes oh so so you're you're the
kid huh and I was like uh yeah and he
goes saw your audition tape man wasn't
good godamn and then just
leaves that was for just Le maybe you
weren't 15 years old enough wrote
[__]
letter was he cooler after or was it
just that he was a little here's the
thing he was he was actually super cool
and he was
so honest which I thought which I like
yeah like there was we at the rap party
we talked a few times she was very cool
but at the rap party and this is where
the honesty comes in I walk up to him
like hey man what's up how are you and
he he looked at me he goes do do you
really care care and I go damn and I go
no not really he goes okay and just
walked away I know that sounds like he's
an [__] like an [__] thing to do
but for some reason I'm like I kind of
like that it's very New York yeah
because I because I I honestly don't
care where's your
wife oh man that's good wow he's a dick
so what how did that like kind of like
sign fish where it's like you know it's
like oh you understand it but it's still
like you didn't have to go meet this guy
and be like oh yeah your audition tape
sucked and just like leave I think it
was unnecessary I do I told I've told
some people this and they all sort of
say the same thing like they were like
playing they were playing mind games
like I think it was a very like mind
gamy thing to do I always hate that like
would do that [__] it's like for what me
what would they do well they would just
be they would tell you it's like a two
we boot camp and I'm the dude top to
bottom the cast wild andado always say
this most talented group of people I've
ever seen insane but they'll be like
okay write a song on this and I don't I
didn't grow up writing [__] songs
rapping whatever but then they'll tell
you this determines how many episodes
you getn and then he'll the guy would
just say [__] like I guess some of y'all
going to be losing episodes I guess some
of y'all and they just like hold that
thing over your head for two weeks I my
confidence got worse and worse and worse
and one thing I did I reached out to the
guy like went to the hotel where all the
wilding out people were stand like dude
like 3 days before we started filming I
was like my confidence has never been
lower I don't know what the [__] is
going on here and then he like coached
me through that a bit but if I didn't
take upon myself to go hey man I this is
a big opportunity and I know it and I
need help that it's just a constant like
we don't give a [__] you you sink or you
swim yeah and I think it's like they
they do that because they need you to be
like a strong-minded person because they
spend all this money on these on these
things on these like sketches I mean are
punks and if you break or you [__] up
like if they if whatever at some point
if some famous person knows that you're
punking them you just lost the company
so much money so you have to like they I
think they have to kind of [__] around
with you to see if you can sort of
handle it you know cuz I I I'm not going
to trust some kid I just met two days
ago with essentially some of these
things were like really high production
this like 400 $500,000 on a production
of like some wild thing it's like bro we
have to know that you can that you can
like handle the heat or whatever sorry I
was going to you know you finish the
point I I was just going to say like I I
would have I would have handled it
different
I think you can middle like middle of
the road
it you know but I mean I don't know
that's what it did it and this show was
you know stupid successful so they
obviously know what the [__] they're
doing also guys I'm not going to waste
time talking sports with these two
because they don't know nothing about it
so if you didn't know I had been on an
unbelievable cold streak on price picks
we're going to keep it going you know
the plan you picked the exact opposite
of what I suggest and that's gonna make
you money also you sign up at price.com
and use the promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100 so
if you invest a hundred you deposit a
100 you get 100 for free it's uh you
really can't lose unless you're me and
then you find a way to lose every week
but that's how you win just pick the
opposite of me